[Musique]
voilà un peu plus d'un mois que la
nouvelle saison de the voice kid a
débuté sur tf1 et le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que le changement de
coach a fait son effet et ça marche
c'est le chanteur kenji qui a rejoint l'
aventure aux côtés de patrick fiori
jennifer et soprano un recrutement qui
semble avoir convaincu les
téléspectateurs sincèrement il y avait
des champions avec 3 6 millions de fans
en moyenne l'émission et en os sur tous
les indicateurs par rapport à la saison
passée
c'est une soirée haute en effet samedi
dernier le programme a même enregistré
une hausse de 690 mille téléspectateurs
sur une semaine
c'est ça devient un monument alors que
les audiences de the voice le vaisseau
amiral sont en chute depuis plusieurs
années passé de 9,1 millions de
téléspectateurs en 2012 à 5,1 millions
la saison dernière on se demande si dans
l'inversion des courbes les deux
programmes ne vont pas finir par se
croiser alors the voice kids plus fort
que the voice
joystiq du fork de vol ce oui non oui
non oui non non non emilie non non non
pas du tout moi je préfère la version
adulte deux oreilles parce que dans ce
qu'ils ya un peu trop de bons sentiments
pour moi je trouve que patrick fiori
même s'il était pas mal au début et
commence à me fatiguer en kenji a été
exceptionnel mère ça très très bonne
recrue
mais on l'a trop de trous union ni entre
autres ou de bons sentiments trop d
enfants ou tu dis mes fans je ne
comprends pas l'idée est en plus de vol
cela arrive avec un nouveau jury qui moi
me fait des frissons à jouer à 5 voilà
et soutenant sa lancée pour la saison
anniversaire à 13 en septembre on
comptait bien c'est une toute petite
saison et après pour la saison je redis
ces zones est une sonnette exactement et
pour la saison 10 on aura viennet on
aura amel bent son art à florent pagny
qui revient donc je suis ravi et marc
lavoine et je trouve que les 4 je pense
que ça va bien marcher il ya un peu de
tout il ya la jeunesse et à la la le
punch avait quand même à nier nous c'est
la vie hier le cas vous avez l'émission
quand même parce que je pouvais je
précise
oui vous vous êtes pas sympa mais alors
ce voile skid g1 j'aime bien les talents
mais ce qui me dérange c'est
effectivement tout le temps le bon
sentiment je trouve pas ça constructif
là où des fois on a des petit récap sur
les coachings des adultes et où c'est
vachement bien de voir comment ils
critiquent et comment ils peuvent les
orienter sur les enfants ne seront rien
dire et c'est trop chaud pis c'est trop
génial mais vous imaginez que non non
mais au moins pour les sélectionnés à
chaque fois c'est oit a trop de talent
c'est super alors qu'il y en a qu'un qui
va gagner à la fin et fo - le
reconnaître quoi alors je trouve une
divine est énervée elle mais aussi
tranquille que non mais non mais je suis
pas trop énerver mais lucas emilie
j'aurais aimé qu'on défonce les enfers
se fait pas par petit à petit de moi
pourquoi je trouve effectivement que
c'est plus fort vous savez il ya un
grand monsieur de la télé qu'ils aient
les enfants sont formidables
doudou et donc jacques martin moi j'ai
ce petit côté madeleine de proust avec
the voice kid ça me rappelle l'école
bissau d'école de vannes personne n'aura
casser les enfants quand ils venaient
chanter enrico macias comme des balais
c'est normal on accueille des enfants
c'est pas des professionnels the voice
ce sont soit des semi professionnels et
où ils veulent faire carrière
les enfants on est gentil avec ça
cartonne parce que les enfants bath and
that's a fait vibrer la corde sensible à
la maison tout simplement il n'y a pas
de de deux jeunes enfants qui ont percé
comme je vois ce normal enfin dame qui
quitta les dents de vol normales
lila lisandro est aussi le petit groupe
mais aujourd'hui on ne les entend plus
ces gens l'attendent et puisqu'on est
dans la musique
j'ai une question j'ai très envie de
faire j'ai des envies
faites moi un petit coup de hache
n'avoir à savourer c'est tant mieux
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
de vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
[Applaudissements]
vva
effectivement j'ai rejoint ce que dit
ludivine c'est parce qu'après il y avait
andré côté professionnel il va se passer
après alors que chez les enfants c'est
encore naturel et encore propre j'ai
rencontré la petite rebecca - week-end
dernier à coeur à elle elle est
exceptionnelle m'a donné des frissons
elle travaille sur le piano elle chante
elle a monté un petit truc avec son papa
et sa maman elle est géniale
il ya 6 et ça en fait c'est plus juste
et ou quoi non mais leur écoute et leur
âge c'est ça qui est beau c'est pas le
rajustement et mignon ça n'a pourtant
rien à personne mais c'est bien